andrew heaney of the yankees is second
start for the angst so with the yankees
and the angels 19 starts combined six
and eight five point four two era
five multi-hit games
this one's set deep to left center field
garden oh
into second base with a lead off double
abraham toro boy he stung that baseball
swing and a miss he strikes out hanager
what a way
zigger batting 216 for the year 23 home
runs and 68 runs batted in
slow breaking ball lifted high and deep
right field
and stanton
cannot get it a two-run homer for kyle
seeger two-nothing mariners in the first
his 24th home run rbi 69 and 70.
and he hearing it already
from the yankee fans at the stadium
two-nothing mariners and chris flexing
has really pitched well for the mariners
this year 10-game winner in his 20 stars
at 375 era
there's a base hit past the lunge in
france
hanukkah will get the ball and fire it
in a lead-off single
for lemayo
3-1
ty france starting at 3-6-3 again
well turned
nicely done
it was aaron judge he was over four last
night but had the big sack flying the
eighth inning that tied the game at one
tripping deep to left there it goes
see ya a monster home run for aaron
judge
and it's 2-1 seattle whoa
did he hit that michael i think you
started there it goes a little too quick
because that was a long home run a
breaking ball 421 feet later
here's the two two
strike three fastball good pitch by
heeney went away
[Music]
base runner for the mariners
hit it hard right field base head
to renz
on the move to third manny will hold him
there a double for jared kelnick with
one out here in the second inning a
couple of runners in scoring position
and he takes it faces are loaded an
opportunity for a hot hitting abraham
toro the 3-2
americans have a 3-1 lead rbi for toro
his seventh
so back-to-back walks three walks in the
inning
a chance for a henniger to blow it open
here and 2-2
fly ball hit well right field
and stanton makes the catch kelnick will
score easily 4-1 mariners
mitch haniger picks up an rbi is 65th
strike three murphy down looking
swing and a miss and a nice bounce back
strong inning for andrew heaney
breaking ball hit the other way
toro
nice play indeed three and two to gallow
got him flex his third strike evans
it's this one on the button jk
to the gap
gardner does not have a great arm and
he's in with the double
couple of doubles for jared kellnick as
we move forward 2-2 pitch
and a big strikeout of audeur great
change-up
1-2 not even chase that one back to back
k's five for the day for chris flexing
that is hammered into right center field
it's a base hit it's gonna split the
outfielders and go to the wall judge
will go for two he will make it no two
to gallow
there it is
that was a big pitch get out of a
possible situation we go to the six four
one mariners here's the one two
and the bits cut on him this has a
breaking ball
oh two half swing did he go
he did
first base umpire lance barrett
swing and a miss
well that's it for hiney he just struck
out the side
and here is odor who has struck out
twice against flexon
lofted down the right field line that
ball is
in the seats a two-run home run for odor
a porch job and the yankees pulled to
within one
listen this to us michael i mean he
stayed through that ball a little bit
more being that change up
a little more time to not be so quick
just enough to get it out of here
yankees back in the game
full pit for the mariners anthony
misevich
48 appearances on the year opponents
hitting 265 against anthony
high fly ball right field hanegar
toward the line he stumbles he can't
make the play he's gonna go to the wall
torre has round second he's going to
third and the throw is wild he will make
it
hiagashioka is going to pinch it for
brantley
that one's driven deep to left field
that ball is going to be
one hop into the seats it's a double
scoring
it's glaber torres it's a pinch hit rbi
double and the yankees tie the game at
four
and now they got to go to casey sadler
after misevich is touched up for
three base error and a ground rule rbi
double
2-2
that one is looped into right field it's
a base hit in front of hannigan he
blocks the ball
as higashiyoka can only go to third he
had to hold up higashioka third lemayo
is at first
that time anthony rizzo chimes in
rounded to first there's one there's a
rundown now the run scores
they just ignored the runner he'll be
tagged out but the yankees take the lead
5-4
it's as if they forgot there was a
runner at third base good base running
by lemayo paul because he stopped
because he knew he had to get in a
rundown
strike three
more down looking a strikeout for clay
holmes
strike three
toro down looking
[Applause]
straight three what a performance by
clay holmes he strikes out the side all
three looking and with the injury to
chapman lawiga is going to try to close
this out now it could be somebody
different all the time although lawazika
has said that he enjoys the intensity of
closing
fly ball left field this should do it
gallows there and the yankees do it
again
they've won five straight